[inaudible].
Yeah.
We wanted to start off this boy though.
You introducing yourself a little bit,
telling us about your general work,
particularly,
you've talked a lot about faculty
freedom recently and I'm wondering if
you think you want to talk a little bit
about what you see as the ideal
relationship between a university and
its faculty members?
Yeah,
I think in many ways the best thing for
the university to do with its faculty
members is to leave them alone.
And I mean that in the best possible
way.
I mean that was actually one of the
things I taught here from 93 to 98 and
one of the things,
and,
and I have the same relationship I would
say with the university at the
University of Toronto,
is that the universities go to a
tremendous amount of trouble to identify
promising people in,
in terms of their research capability
from all over the world.
And generally speaking,
if you identify promising people your
best bet as a manager is to stay out of
their way now and to remove obstacles
from their,
from their movement forward.
And I think that the universities do a
credible job of that.
Although my sense,
uh,
over the last few decades has been that
increasingly there are more impediments
placed in the path of,
of research.
For example,
I've seen that with the multiplication
of the powers of,
of institutional review boards,
for example,
ethics committees,
which have vastly overreached there.
They're there,
they're reasonable powers and they slow
things down.
And that's a big mistake.
If you're dealing with people who are,
are conducting research into important
topics,
then you want to do everything you
possibly can to let them move forward as
rapidly as possible.
In what ways do you think these
institutional review boards or these
ethics committees had particularly
damage the process where the speed of
research research?
Do you think there are times,
like,
do you have any examples in mind of when
you think they've overreached their
power?
Well,
the rate they regulate think your mind
for
I gotta ask him.
That one's not on yet.
Okay.
Well let's find it.
Okay,
awesome.
That's better.
Okay.
Oh,
you can hear me.
Which at least in principle should be an
improvement.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
Oh yes,
that's much better.
Yeah.
No.
It in,
in the social sciences,
for example,
the institutional review boards insist
upon reviewing the use of questionnaires
in research,
which I think is,
is it's,
it's not helpful.
Hmm.
Questionnaires aren't dangerous and they
have no real policies set in place to
determine the difference between
dangerous research and the normal
dangerous that people expose them to
cells on to,
on a daily basis.
So,
um,
and they've certainly,
the institutional review boards have
certainly slow down the work in my lab,
for example,
and made it much more onerous.
We have to do a tremendous amount of
writing and justification for this
study's long before they're even
undertaken.
And then also to do a fair bit of
paperwork to keep up with the
documentation.
And I don't find that the least bit
useful.
And I know that in the United States,
the institutional review boards domains
of power being cut back now because of
complaints,
primarily,
if I remember correctly,
primary from the,
primarily from the granting agencies
because they're adding to the
unnecessary expense that's associated
with research.
So in the university should the
university administration fundamentally
exists to serve the faculty and the
students,
and probably the students first and the
faculty second.
But increasingly I see that the
administration is,
is multiplying out of control and,
and that's quite well documented in
terms of overall cost and some of that's
driven by legislation.
And so it's not,
it's not something that's necessarily
intrinsic to the administration itself,
but that's one of the things that's
driving the spiraling up ever,
ever upward spiring of tuition costs.
So aside from research ethics boards,
Institutional Review Boards,
ethics committees,
do you think that there are other ways
that the administration has interfered
with your work,
particularly?
You've recently come under fire by some
administration at the University of
Toronto for certain controversial views
you hold.
You mentioned that you think the
administration's primary obligation
should be to its students and then it
should also serve as faculty.
Do you see the administration using that
mission properly when they try to talk
to faculty about certain statements that
they've made,
or do you think that's also an overreach
of their power?
Well,
I think it reflects a more general
societal confusion about just exactly
what our priorities are.
I made a video back in September stating
my objections to the mandated use of a
certain category of Pronoun that I
object to mostly on the grounds that I
felt that the government had no right
compelling people's speech and also
because personally I didn't want to use
the pronouns that were being put forward
by people I regard as holding up
philosophical and political ethos that I
find really quite detestable.
And I made a video about that and
mentioned during the video that the act
of making the video had probably become,
had arguably become illegal and Ontario
in the province I'm from and was about
to become illegal federally with some
new legislation and that it likely
violated the,
the code of conduct that,
that,
that characterize the university with
regards to its inclusiveness policies.
University promptly validated my
concerns by sending me two letters,
telling me to stop making such
statements because they violated the
university's code of conduct and also
the relevant human rights legislation in
Ontario and in the federal government.
And one of the,
I felt that the reason that the
university did that was because they
faced a certain amount of public
pressure from people at the University
of Toronto.
And that would be mostly,
most of that pressure came from people I
would regard as the professional
activist types.
And the university said that they hadn't
received many letters accusing me of
making the University of Toronto an
unsafe space,
which is the sort of language that
immediately makes you know that you're
dealing with people who are
ideologically possessed.
But they also,
but they failed to note at the same time
that they had received hundreds,
perhaps thousands of letters as well as
a 10,000 signature petition supporting
my stance.
And so I think when the administration,
uh,
when,
when the administration regarding it's
duty,
it's fundamental duty to promote some
illusory notion of safety and then also
is willing to falsify the facts on the
ground by omission that definitely
overstepped their boundaries.
And I would say that,
uh,
they were,
they were put back,
they were set back on their heels,
let's put it that way,
by a very,
uh,
strident outpouring,
strident,
powerful outpouring of public opinion in
Canada.
And that was all the,
that was good for me because I got two
letters.
And generally if you're dealing with
human resources professionals,
then three letters is the warning and
then the next step is something more
serious.
I'm curious,
and you mentioned the term safe space in
particular for a university,
and I want you to link this back to this
idea that university administration
should be serving students first and
faculty second.
So do you think that the administration
has some sort of compelling mandate to
make sure that students feel safe?
No,
they haven't.
They have exactly the reverse mandate.
There's nothing safe about being
educated.
If you want to be safe,
stay home,
the things that you need to be educated
about our terrible things.
Almost always,
if you study history properly,
it's terrible.
If you study literature properly,
If you study psychology properly,
all of these fields of endeavor teach
you the painful things that you need to
know to understand what human beings in
society or like.
And so the idea,
first of all,
the idea that universities should be a
safe space is absolutely preposterous,
but it's also preposterous for more,
more,
I would say immediate reasons.
So one of the,
one of the,
there's a few things that we know is as
clinical psychologists,
uh,
as,
as a field and also as practitioners
with regards to how to treat people who
suffer,
let's say from an excess of anxiety.
And what you do with people who suffer
from an excess of anxiety is expose them
to the very things that they're afraid
of or sometimes disgusted by.
And you,
you help them voluntarily expose
themselves to such things.
And that doesn't make the world safer.
It makes them braver and more competent.
And so the,
the notion that you serve students,
uh,
safety concerns,
even by shielding them from things that
they don't wish to encounter.
There's,
there's absolutely,
I can't think of a single possible,
a valid reason why you would ever
undertake such an endeavor.
I think it's really neat to talk about
it in the abstract,
but that particular concern that perhaps
a lot of students and a lot of members
of the community have with your case
is the particular pronoun usage issue.
So in that instance,
I'm wondering if you think there's a
real harm.
So if someone comes to you,
one of your students let's say,
and would really feel more comfortable
engaging with the deep,
troubling historical or psychological or
whatever field truths,
if you refer to the student with certain
pronouns,
do you really think that's a necessary
place where they need that,
you know,
severe exposure or do you think there is
some sort of harm by calling them the
Pronoun that
they will?
I think it's fundamentally a fabricated
issue.
It's been fabricated for political
reasons.
I know the history of the relevant
legislation in Ontario and initially the
legislation was basically predicated on
the idea that that gender identity was a
social construct and that they're there,
we're going to be protections put in
place for people whose gender identity
had switched so that they weren't
subject to harassment or discrimination
and there's no utility in subjecting
people to counterproductive
discrimination.
And I would consider discrimination
counterproductive when the
discrimination occurs for reasons that
aren't relevant to the task at hand.
Sure.
Cause we discriminate all the time.
But the,
the,
the government ran the policies by a
relatively select group of,
of activists and,
and transformed it into a,
a piece of policy legislation that no
one in their right mind would abide by
or could abide by for that matter and
reduced,
for example,
the idea of human identity to something
that basically transforms on a
subjective whim.
And so I don't buy any of that.
I don't,
I don't think that that's what identity
is.
I don't think it's fundamentally self
generated.
It might be socio culturally
constructive to some degree and it most
certainly is.
But the idea that your identity is
solely your choice and that you have the
right to inflict that on other people is
absolutely preposterous.
Most people grow out of that idea when
they're two years of age.
And,
and I mean that technically because we
know that when children hit about three
years of age,
they're able to start playing social
games and that's when they start
learning that that identity is a,
is at minimum a socially negotiated
phenomena now.
Okay.
So apart from that,
there's no agreement whatsoever on the
set of pronouns that will be used and
they've multiplied beyond anybody's,
anybody's imagination,
I would say including the people who
formulated the legislation.
And then there's the fact that you don't
refer to people by their pronouns
anyways.
They're third person pronouns.
And so I don't call you,
he,
when we're talking,
I might refer to you as he,
if I was talking about you with someone
else.
So most of the time it's a moot point
anyways.
But doctor computers,
it says where it does matter,
right?
Because certainly you could envision,
let's not talk so much about federal
policy,
but perhaps like in an actual like
personal day to day setting,
do you think there is a harm?
So perhaps you can disagree with like
the philosophical principle,
the theoretical truth of whether or not
identity can change subjectively with to
win.
But if someone comes up to me and says,
you know,
I want to be referred to as this,
even if I adopt some sort of view that I
don't really think fundamentally on a
pure theoretical level,
they have an understanding of identity.
Do does that,
do I then choose to harm them or
potentially upset to them by sticking to
my belief about what their identity is?
Well,
the first thing you'd have to establish
is whether or not that would actually
constitute harm.
That's the claim.
And the person might say,
well,
you're harming me,
but that doesn't provide evidence that
you are people.
People presume very often that they're
harmed by things,
that they're not harmed by it at all.
So I don't think that the mere claim
that someone thinks that the way I would
address the might harm them gives them
the right to enforce by legislation the
content of my speech.
I'd have just doesn't that doesn't,
that doesn't work.
And you know,
here's something else that's worth
noting from a more practical
perspective.
I mean,
um,
I've received letters from about 30
trends people and that's actually a lot
because there aren't that many people
and these are people who by and large,
we're very serious about their
transformations and all.
But one of them agreed with what I was
doing saying first of all,
that they never asked to be represented
by the activist to claim to be
representing them.
No.
So here's a proposition,
right?
So imagine that there's a group of
people and that somebody is a member of
that group of people and then that
person stands forthe as a member of that
group and says,
because I'm a member of that group,
I speak for all those people.
It's like,
actually,
no,
you don't.
The mere fact that you're the member of
a group,
it doesn't give you any right whatsoever
to speak on behalf of that group.
You need to have legitimacy as a
representative and I don't,
I think that that you can hardly imagine
a more pernicious,
uh example say of racism then to presume
that if someone is black,
they speak on behalf of all black
people.
All black people are homogenous.
They all believe exactly the same thing.
Therefore,
if you talked to or met one of them
you've talked to or met them all,
but there's that Dr. Peterson,
I think I'm referring to cases where the
actual people in front of you are
telling you though that they want to,
they want to represent themselves a
certain way.
Right.
So we can talk about whether or not to
the activist community is accurately
representing actual communities.
But I'm wondering,
you mentioned you don't think like a
self report of like,
Oh this is harming me or I would not be
comfortable interacting with you unless
you know,
x happened would not be an accurate way
of describing real harm.
Are there better metrics we have for
real harm?
If someone comes up to me and they say,
Oh,
you know,
when they are feeling too warm in this
room,
we should leave,
you know,
do I say,
ah,
no.
Like you don't know how warm you are.
That's not something you can know for
yourself.
That's just the self report.
Well,
it would depend on what they were asking
other people to do and I don't,
I don't believe that people have the
right to impose restrictions on what,
not so much restrictions on what I'm
allowed to say,
but to determine the content of my
speech,
that's an entirely different thing.
And so if it's a matter of the legal
principle of whether or not I'm free to
determine the content of my speech or
the hypothetical discomfort of a
hypothetical person because no one's
actually asked me this yet.
Okay,
then I'm going to go with the freedom
from compelled speech.
Partly again,
because I think that the idea that the
government or any other institution
should regulate the content of your
speech is absolutely,
and it's intolerable.
I think you have a strong legal
argument.
Right?
So the government probably shouldn't
mandate this,
that I'm sure a lot of people might
agree with that.
I'm still curious though,
in this hypothetical scenario that a
student did or a person did approach you
and they told you they would be harmed
or they would be uncomfortable unless
you refer to them with a certain
pronoun.
Yeah.
What would you do?
Well,
I really have a hard time answering
questions like that because they're
asked in the hypothetical.
It could certainly it could.
Yeah,
it could,
but my sense,
because I'm a clinician,
is that I generally handle those sorts
of things at the level of actual detail.
So I would say it would depend on the
person.
It would depend on the situation.
It would depend on why they asked me.
It would depend on how they asked me.
It would depend on what I thought they
were trying to accomplish by the
request.
It would,
it would depend on whether or not they
were filming me.
Well,
they were asking me.
It would depend on whether they asked me
in my office or in a hallway,
you know,
I can tell the difference between a
genuine plea for understanding and a bit
of political theater or political
manipulation.
Hm.
Now and I've dealt with people who've
made all sorts of requests of me,
believed me because I've had a clinical
practice for about 20 years and my
experience with,
with the range of human behavior is I
would say extraordinarily extensive.
And so I've made all sorts of
adjustments to the way I interact with
people.
So I can't say exactly what I would do
in a given situation because I firmly
believe that the devil is in the details
and I haven't been making a case about a
specific interaction that I had actually
experienced or,
or,
yeah,
experienced.
I'd been making a case,
a philosophical fundamentally if
philosophical case and secondarily a
political case and I think that I've
made the case properly,
but you would say that you'd recognize a
difference between a like legal
responsibility to do something versus
it's sort of an individual personal
choice.
I should do something right.
Sometimes I recognize that.
I mean sometimes the legal and the
philosophical and the personal issue are
all the same.
It's simpler when that's the case,
but I also think that the issue is
essentially a red herring.
I mean,
look,
since I made that video for one reason
or another,
the things that I've been saying have
become quite popular and and not as
controversial as you might think.
Most of what I've accrued so far is
being support and the reason for that
has very little to do with the issue of
pronouns.
The Pronoun issue in the Pronoun
controversy is a pointer to something
that's a lot larger and that's why this
issue has had legs.
I'm not here because people are
interested in my views on pronouns.
Now I happen to put my foot down so to
speak at a particular place because it's
very frequently the case that if you're
engaged in a complex philosophical
dispute,
which is the case for our society in
general,
that in order to make a,
to make a statement about it,
you have to make a statement in to an
actual cause.
So you have to draw the line somewhere.
And people have asked me,
well,
why did you pick the Pronoun Hill to die
on?
And my answer to that generally is a,
I didn't die.
And B,
you have to and be,
you have to,
you have to pick something real yeah.
To,
to enter into the debate.
So for example,
if I would have just made another video
decrying political correctness,
it would've gone nowhere at all.
But I said that there was something I
wouldn't do.
And one of the things I won't do is use
the made upwards of postmodern neo
Marxist who are playing a particular
game with gender identity.
That's an extension of their particular
reprehensible philosophy.
And if that happens to me in that,
um,
I have to engage in discussions about
whether or not if a,
you know,
if,
uh,
a suffering and confused person who's
had a,
who's had a very like,
troubled pathway through life came and
asked me politely if I would go out of
my way to accommodate them.
I think that,
I don't think that those issues actually
belong on the same,
in the same,
they're not the same category of issue.
I mean,
so,
so I don't see that there's,
well I guess that's enough set of boat
that.
All right,
let's transition a little bit.
So you mentioned sort of postmodernism
and neo Marxism,
in fact in a statement and mcmaster
university,
you claimed that an expression of that,
the protest that you see at your events
are an expression of a philosophy that's
grounded partly in postmodernism and
partly in Marxism.
Yeah.
What does that mean first and secondly,
how would you say that these movements
are characterize in those ways?
Well,
at mcmaster it meant that some of the
protesters came with,
came and hid behind a banner that had a
hammer and sickle on it.
You know?
So you see,
the funny thing is,
is that people laugh about that and,
and I understand perfectly well what
while you're laughing,
but I can tell you,
you wouldn't have laughed if it would
have been a swastika and it's,
no,
it's no funnier that it was a hammer.
And sickle,
you know,
the,
the reprehensible ideologies that are
based in,
in fundamental Marxism killed at least
100 million people in the 20th century.
And there's still apologist one in five.
Social scientists identifies as a
Marxist.
It's like,
really,
really?
That's really,
that's really where we're going to take
this.
Is it after the bloody 20th century,
we're going to say,
well,
that wasn't real communism or something
foolish like that.
Even though we had multiple examples of
exactly what happens when those
doctrines are let loose in the world.
And so what,
what happened in the 1960s in the late
1960s as far as I can tell,
and this happened mostly in France,
which has probably produced the most
reprehensible coterie of public
intellectuals that any country has ever
managed,
is that in,
in the,
in the late 1960s when all the student
activists,
uh,
had decided that the Marxist revolution
wasn't going to occur in the western
world.
And,
and,
and had finally also realized that
apologizing for the Soviet,
for the Soviet system was just not going
to fly anymore.
Given,
given the tens of millions of bodies
that had stacked up that they performed
a,
what I would call a philosophical
sleight of hand and transformed the
class war into a,
into a identity politics,
politics,
war.
And that became extraordinarily popular,
mostly transmitted through people like
shock Derrida,
who became an absolute darling of the
Yale English department and had his
pernicious doctrines spread throughout
North America partly as a consequence of
his invasion of Yale.
And what happened with the,
what,
what happened with the postmodernist is
they kept on pedaling their,
their,
their murderous breed of,
of political doctrine under a new guys
and resentful people all over the world
fell for it.
And I don't,
I don't consider that acceptable.
I,
you know,
one of the things I've learned,
for example,
I teach my students in my second year
personality class about what happened in
the Soviet Union and in the Gulag
archipelago.
And I use soldier Nitsa and has an
exemplar Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn as an
exemplar of existential psychology
because I think he's actually the wisest
of the existential psychologist even
though he was primarily a historian in
literary finger.
Well,
most of the students don't even know
what happened in the Soviet Union.
Well why is that exactly.
And the reason for that is that radical
leftist ideologue,
intellectuals in the West have never
properly apologized for the row for the
role they played in the and the absolute
murderousness of the,
of the 20th century.
And so students don't even know about
it.
So they can come out to mcmaster behind
there,
they're damn mineable poster with a
hammer and sickle on it and act like
they're virtuous.
Do you think it's a calling,
getting that trend was only sort of
significant to that specific mcmaster
incident?
Or do you see this type of ideology
influencing campus protests beyond
mcmaster in general?
Well,
I think the,
I think that that part of it,
it's everywhere.
It's not just in campus protests.
I mean the,
the campuses are,
are,
are overrun in large part with
disciplines that have,
in my estimation,
no valid reason to exist.
I think disciplines like women's studies
should be defunded.
Any of the activists disciplines who
act,
who,
who's primarily primary role is the
overthrow us.
Uh,
for example,
of the patriarchy,
which is about is ill defined the
concept as you could possibly formulate
that it's enough that we've,
we've done enough public funding of that
sort of thing.
We're providing,
we're providing full time destructive
employment for people who are doing
nothing but causing trouble and
seriously nothing.
You would say that because you think
that these departments are causing harm
or it could have the potential to cause
harm that university administrations to
defund them,
right?
No,
I don't think they should be fun to.
Who the hell cares what I think about
them?
That's why I think that they should be
defunded at all.
Okay.
I think they should be defunded because
what they promote has a zero
intellectual credibility.
Their research methods don't qualify as
research methods.
There are publications,
80% of humanities publications now
Garner zero citations.
That's not very citations and it's
a little trick as far as I can tell is
what happens is that people write
something that no one will read.
They know perfectly well.
That new one will read it.
They circulated around there.
They're tiny group of compatriots who
occupied the same little,
little what a little area on the
intellectual spectrum.
So then it's peer reviewed then is
published by major journals who sell it
at inflated prices to libraries who
squirreled away to end and only increase
the noise to signal ratio in
relationship to the sum total of human
knowledge.
It's a scam from top to bottom.
So,
and you know,
one of the exam,
well let me give you an example.
So here's one of the things that really
bothered me about what was going on in
Ontario.
And this is happening everywhere.
And I made,
I made this claim when I made my first
video,
since we have to get into this.
So the technical claim in the Ontario
legislature legislation now,
and this is how this has already
happened in New York,
by the way,
this is not only a Canadian thing,
it's happening in Australia,
it's happening in New Zealand,
it's happening everywhere.
Here's the claim.
There's biological sex,
there's gender identity,
there's gender expression and their
sexual proclivity.
And they vary independently.
That's the technical claim.
It's built into the Canadian law.
That's not true.
Not at all.
Not a bit of that is true.
The correlation between biological sex
and gender identity exceeds 0.99 it's
virtually perfect.
It's the very definition of non
independent.
So you think almost everyone who is
biologically male identifies as
biologically male,
almost everyone who identifies as
biologically male dresses and acts mail.
That's the gender identity element.
And almost everybody who is biologically
male who identifies as male who dresses
as male is in fact heterosexual.
Most things are incredibly tightly
linked.
But the technical claim in the
legislation is that they vary
independently wrong.
Now I got in trouble for saying that
because what people claimed was that I
was denying the existence of people who
don't fit neatly into the gendered
categories,
which I wasn't doing it a zero one or
whatever the percentage may be.
That wouldn't fall neatly under that.
So suddenly if there were a perfect
correlation,
that would work.
But if there's not,
it would seem perhaps that you're
excluding certain people.
Right?
So if,
if most people tend to identify a
certain way,
but there is that 0.01 that's not,
I wasn't ever denying their existence.
I was denying the validity of the claim
that those four levels of analysis
existed independently of one another,
which they don't.
It's a false claim.
And the reason that the,
the radical social constructionist who
are pursuing this line of reasoning,
which is completely discredited as far
as I'm concerned,
I don't think it's any better than
claiming that the world is flat.
The reason that they're pursuing it
legally is because they know perfectly
well that they've lost the scientific
discussion.
I mean,
I debated someone on Canadian public
television who had the gall to say that
the,
you know,
the scientific consensus over the last
four decades was that there was no
biological differences between men and
women.
I mean,
and that was one of the things that was
so absurd about
that.
And there were many things that were
absurd about it,
was that I was in trouble with the
university at that point and he wasn't.
It's like first of all,
that is,
that is not the scientific consensus of
the last four decades.
Since the idea of it,
there are no biological differences
between men and women.
It's the sort of thing you hear that it
just makes your jaw drop.
Now what you could say is that if you
took all the dimensions along which men
and women very,
and there's a substantial number of
them,
that there's substantial overlap between
men and women on almost all of the
dimensions.
Now that's not particularly true with
chromosomal identity,
although there are some exceptions like
with personality for example,
and I happened to be somewhat of an
expert on personality.
There are marked differences between men
and women,
but the overlap exceeds the differences.
So for example,
women are higher in agreeableness and
you might say,
well that's socio culturally
constructed.
But it turns out that it isn't because
if you look across cultures and you,
you look at the cultures that have moved
most forward with um,
with gender equality provisions up the
social and political lead levels and
that would be the Scandinavian
countries,
the differences in personality between
women,
men and women maximize in those
countries.
And these are tiny studies.
These are studies that involve tens of
thousands of people and that have been
well replicated by a series of
independent researchers.
And so with,
with,
per,
if you add the personality differences
between men and women across all the
personality traits,
you can almost perfectly segregate men
from women.
And that has not,
that,
that doesn't take into account the
obvious things like arm angle and hip
width,
hip,
hip with compared to,
to waste with and shoulder width and
upper body strength and height and
weight and the biochemical differences.
And I mean it's,
it's so preposterous that it's,
it's,
it's beyond conception to me that we're
actually even discussing it.
But I was making a specific claim,
which is the law says these four levels
of analysis very independently.
The only reason they're associated with
one another is for cultural reasons,
no wrong.
And you don't get to put fallacious
scientific truths into the law,
not,
or if you're going to do that then I'm
not going to abide by that particular
law.
I'm going to object to it,
which is exactly what I shouldn't be
doing.
So do you think that a necessary premise
for us to accept to have a law like
that,
a law that extends protections and these
groups is that these identities are
independent from each other fully
independent?
No.
Could we accept like if they had just
justified it as we know that these
aren't fully independent,
but we think there are other good
reasons to provide these protections.
What do you be,
what your stance on the law change?
Well,
the law as it's currently formulated
doesn't in fact it undermines the
protection that these sorts of groups
have been pursuing is seeking for years.
So let's say let's take the let's,
let's accept the proposition that these
very independently or or that they're
only socio culturally constructed.
Okay,
so where does
that leave your discussion of
homosexuality?
So if they,
if the fundamentalist Christians say,
well,
if,
if homosexuality is nothing butter
socio-cultural construct and why do we
have to put up with it?
It's a perfectly valid argument.
And he's say,
well no,
you know,
people,
people are born into their sexual
proclivity.
Now I'm not saying that they are not
because I'm not making either of those
courses.
What I am pointing out is that the
legislation and policies of that sword
as currently formulated actually
undermine the very arguments that many
of the activists groups have been using
to promote the fact that they,
they are,
they're deserving,
let's say that they're deserving of
their,
of their non standard identity,
that the nonstandard identities is
justifiable.
If your sexual proclivity is nothing but
a whim,
then why should I put up with it?
Hmm.
No,
it's perfectly reasonable for me to say
no.
Well,
we'll just reshape it because you're in,
you're infinitely malleable now.
You know it,
it isn't exactly,
we don't exactly know the degree to
which such things as let's say sexual
identity and sexual proclivity are
biologically predicated or socio
culturally instantiated,
but when you,
when you put forward legislation that
insists on one to the exclusion of the
other,
you better be careful because you're
going to be hooked,
hooked in your own news.
And so when I read through the
legislation and the policies that
surrounded that,
I thought this isn't going to protect
the people that it's supposed to
protect,
but it doesn't matter because the
legislation was never designed to
protect people.
It was designed to advance a certain
kind of political agenda,
which is partly why I'm objecting.
I'm objecting to it,
so I'm not willing in the slightest to
presume that just because activist
groups with this postmodern Neil Marxist
ethic stand up and say,
well,
we're on the side of the oppressed,
that that makes them a on the side of
the oppressed or be virtuous.
I don't buy either of those arguments.
I don't think they stand for what they
say they stand for.
I don't think they're promoting a
doctrine that is going to do what they
claim it will do.
I don't believe that they're good in the
rest of the world,
bad.
I don't buy their oppressor victim
dichotomy.
I don't admire their philosophical
position.
I think they don't know anything about
history or if they do know anything
about history,
then they're malevolent for pursuing
exactly the same policies that led us
into terrible situations before.
So in what ways do you think the
policies that are being advocated,
maybe you could talk a bit about the
particular harms you think that this
Canadian bill would have,
even if we don't accept the theoretical
or political or historical rationale for
the bail.
Could it be that it's still produces
good consequences or do you think that
there is even a consequentialist
argument against this sort of bill?
And if so,
what do you think?
The big letters that I've received from
the transsexual people I described
indicate instantly that it's not
producing positive positive effects at
all.
And he said after saying,
well,
our political views aren't homogenous
and we don't like being treated as if
they were.
And these activists don't speak for us.
They say,
look,
most of us would just like to be a
little bit more invisible if we could.
And all this terrible concentration on
preferred pronouns and,
and identification of transsexual people
has made our lives a living hell.
Well and no wonder,
because it's hard to imagine you're
imagine that you are having real trouble
with your gender identity.
You know,
and you're a six foot one guy and you
want to transform yourself into a woman.
It's going to be hard enough for you to
be,
you know,
cause I invisible in a socially
acceptable way without a bunch of people
who purport to be speaking on your
behalf,
making this like issue do juror for
their political reasons.
And that's exactly what the letter
writers have been telling me.
So.
So no,
I don't,
I don't see that.
I mean the,
the legislation is,
was incoherent as originally formulated.
Then it was made worse by its shopping
before activist groups.
There no evidence whatsoever that will
have the outcomes that the,
that the people who formulated it
hypothetically desire because I don't
believe that they desire the best
possible outcome anyways.
The people look,
the people who are formulating these
sorts of policies state quite
forthrightly,
so for example,
if you go look at women's studies
websites,
they state quite forthrightly that their
aim is the destruction of the
patriarchy,
whatever the hell that is.
You know what I mean?
And that that's a good indication of the
level of intellectual sophistication
that goes into this sort of thinking.
What is this patriarchy exactly?
Well,
what is it exactly?
I mean,
if we're going to talk about it,
it's,
it's male domination of everything and
nothing but oppression.
It's like,
really that's how we're going to define
our society.
Is it compared to what society?
Exactly.
Where if people be more free than they
are,
for example,
in this country,
that doesn't mean they're perfectly
free,
but you know,
forget that that's never going to
happen.
It's like,
well,
this is an oppressive place compared to
my height,
the hypothetical utopia that I would
produce if I happen to be,
you know,
uh,
stolen for a week and are as I've,
as I've always,
as I've already pointed out,
if you were the,
the hypothetical,
um,
altruistic Utopian of your imagination,
then the people right behind you and
your bloody revolution would stab you to
death in your bed and you wouldn't get
to make your decisions for the benefit
of anyone every anyways.
So how do you think progress should be
made in a world where we are freer than
we have ever been?
Do you think we,
like when are there changes that are
desirable to be made and how would you
want to see them implemented,
if not through policy or through
activism?
The way that certain groups currently
are promotable back?
You know,
this happened in the 60s as far as I can
tell that we've got this misbegotten
idea that the way to conduct yourself as
a,
as a responsible human being was to hold
plaque cards up to protest,
to change the viewpoints of other people
and thereby usher in the utopia.
It's like,
I think,
I think that's all appalling.
I think it's appalling and I think it's
absolutely,
it's absolutely observed that students
are taught that that's the way to
conduct themselves in the world.
First of all,
if you're 19 or 20 or 21 you don't
bloody well know anything.
You haven't done anything.
You don't know anything about history.
You haven't read anything.
You haven't supported yourself for any
length of time.
You've been entirely dependent on your
state and on
your family for the,
for the brief few years of your
existence and the idea that you have
enough wisdom to determine how society
should be reconstructed when you're
sitting in the absolute lap of luxury
protected by,
by,
by processes that you don't understand
is absolutely,
I mean it's okay,
so that's a bad,
let's call that a bad idea.
Sure.
She all wait.
And then the idea that what you should
do to change the world is to find people
who you disagree with in shake paper on
sticks at them and call them names is
also so,
and then you do that before you go out
for here.
Oh,
I'll tell you how serious the activists
are.
This is something that's just
unbelievably comical as far as I'm
concerned.
So some of you may know that.
Um,
I participated in a debate on free
speech,
so called debate at free speech that the
University of Toronto hosted.
Um,
it turned into a forum and,
and whatever that is,
but it's certainly not a debate.
But one of the things I did when I was
talking to the university administration
was to suggest how they might deal with
the possibility of protestors.
So I said,
well,
that's easy.
I can know how you can have absolutely
zero protesters,
um,
habit in the morning.
They won't get out of bed in the town.
So we had it at nine o'clock in the
morning and there was one MP member of
parliament who showed up to hand out
some pamphlets and not a single
protester.
Oh.
It's like if you want a controversial
speaker on campus,
just have it at seven in the morning.
You won't get a protestor within 50
yards of it because they'll still be
sleeping off last night's part and the
alcohol induced hangover.
Okay.
So,
so let me know when this question was.
What do I think people should do?
And I'll tell you something that's been
very interesting to me and I can see it
reflected here.
The first thing I've noticed is that,
um,
when I started putting my videos on
youtube,
which was about three years ago,
I noticed that about 85% of the people
that were watching the more men,
and I thought that's pretty weird
because about 80% of my students are
women.
You know,
because men are bailing out of
universities like mad and there won't be
one in the social sciences and
humanities left in 10 years.
But you know,
nobody seems particularly worried about
that.
You can go look that up online if you
want,
and look at the enrollment curves and
just project them 10 years out into the
future.
And I'd been following that for about 20
years.
But one of the things,
but online it was,
so it was 85% men.
I thought,
wow,
that's really weird and strange.
And then I made these political videos
and then it popped up to 91% men.
And then I've noticed in the audiences
that I've gone to talk to that it's
almost all men now.
Just look around here man.
It's like,
what?
It's gotta be 90% guys in this audience.
And I thought,
what the Hell is going on?
It's weird.
And I noticed that at the first free
speech debate at the University of
Toronto,
I made a point of it.
I walked into the room and I thought,
wow,
these are all men.
So I had the stand up and the women
stand up and I used that as an example
of the fact that maybe men and women
have different interests.
It was,
you know,
just an ad hoc demonstration.
But it's really been born out by the
demographic analysis of my viewers and I
have,
you know,
several about 8 million views or
something like that now.
So it's a pretty big population.
I haven't been talking nonstop about
personal responsibility and about the
fact that if you want to change the
world,
you should bloody well get your act
together and quit whining and sniveling
about how horrible everything is and
about how people will you more rights
and more privileges.
And for some reason that seems to be a
message that's really resonating and
among young men.
And I think the reason for that,
first of all,
I think young women have enough to do.
And so that's perhaps part of the reason
why the message isn't as necessary for
them.
They're trying to juggle career,
they're trying to figure out how to have
a family and they don't really have any
question about whether or not that's
useful and proper.
So they're off doing that and,
and whatever else they're doing.
But young men seem to have more of a
choice about that.
And many of them are essentially bailing
out.
And it's partly because I think they'd
been well punished for their virtues.
And so I talked to young guys in
particular about,
you know,
adopting some responsibility and trying
to straighten out their lives and to
bear the load of being properly into
forthrightly move through existence and
to become a credit to themselves and
their community.
And that's what you should do instead of
waving cards at someone,
telling them to behave more property
because you're morally superior to them.
So,
and for some reason that message,
which is,
it's a really,
it's not the sort of message that you
would expect to sell,
right?
It's the exactly the opposite of
something that you would consider a
salable.
But my experience has been that the
young men in particular are so bloody
desperate for that message that they can
hardly stand themselves.
And,
and it's no wonder because it's a call
to,
it's a call to proper being,
it's a call to heroic being and it's a
call for people to adopt their
individual responsibility and to
straighten themselves out and to find
out what they can be like if they took
on the burdens of existence,
like,
like respectable,
well-educated,
articulate,
powerful people.
And that's ducks to the benefit of
everyone.
And so while it's,
so that's where the responsibility lies.
And I'm not interested in the,
I've thought for many,
many years,
decades really about having a political
career.
I mean,
I was interested in a political career
when I was 13 and so every five years or
so I've probably revisited that.
But every time I revisited,
I came to the same conclusion,
which was that the,
the work that I was doing that was
focused on a philosophy of individual
responsibility and trying to identify
how that philosophy had emerged in the
West over thousands of years was more
important than any possible political
action could be.
And I still don't regard what I'm doing
as political in any sense of the word.
I think it's,
I think it's still esophageal most
accurately and there's an element of
that.
It's theological,
so,
so I think it's individual
responsibility and the meaning of life
is to be found in the adoption of
individual responsibility.
And that's what the university should be
teaching people.
So Dr. Peterson,
you've mentioned these ideas of
responsibility,
of virtue of respect.
You've I think,
detailed.
What do you think students shouldn't do?
And these examples of like protests
and these examples of certain types of
activist tactics.
What advice would you have for students?
How can students make the changes that
they want to make?
Particularly,
do you have any advice for students
here?
Yeah.
Read great books.
Really,
man,
you've got this four year period that
has been carved out of your lives by
society.
They,
they,
it's,
it's given you an identity,
like a high quality identity and freedom
at the same time.
And you're not going to get that again
in your life.
You've got to,
you've got a respectable identity,
university student and complete freedom
associated with that or as near as
you're ever going to get.
And you've got these unbelievable
libraries that are full of the writings
of people who were,
who are intelligent and articulate
beyond comprehension and you know,
and,
and you can go there and you can learn
all this and you might think,
well why should you learn it?
Um,
well you learn it to get a job or you
learn it to get good grades or you learn
it to get a degree.
And that's all nonsense.
It's nonsense.
The reason that you come to university
to be educated is because there is
nothing more powerful than someone who
is articulate and who can think and
speak.
It's power,
I mean power of the best sort and its
authority and influence and
respectability and competence.
And so you come to the university to
craft your highest skill and your
highest skill is to be found in
articulated speech.
And if you're,
if you're,
if you're a master at formulating your
arguments,
you win everything.
And better than that,
when you win everything,
everyone around you wins too.
Because to transform yourself into,
let's consider you consider your
transformation into something
approximating the logos.
It means you shine a light on the whole
world.
Well,
there's nothing more exciting to do than
that.
There's nothing better you can possibly
do.
And to think that you're going to
university to be trained to have a job,
it's like great.
That's a hell of a lot better than being
unemployed and covered with cheeto dust
while you're snacking away in front of
your video game in the basement.
But it's not.
It's not a,
and I don't have anything against video
games by the way,
but it's hardly a triumphant call to to
being in the world.
And that's what universities should be
calling forth.
It's like God,
you people,
as you know,
I know what Harvard students are like.
I taught here for five years.
You people are spectacular.
You're spectacular.
You're,
you're,
you're all capable of being world
beaters.
You transform yourself into something
that's articulated and sensible and
grounded in history and knowledgeable
and wise.
Man,
you can do anything you want and
hopefully anything you want for good
because if you have any sense,
everything you want to do would be for
the good because there's nothing more
compelling or meaningful or or useful in
combating the tragedy of life than to,
than to struggle with all your soul on
behalf of the good and the university's
isn't forgotten,
Matt.
It's what everyone's bailing out of the
humanities and they should,
the humanities are corrupt and they're
corrupt because they're not telling
students this.
It's so bloody obvious.
It's like learn to think,
learn to speak loom to it makes you a
super power and individual superpower
you have
under.
I know what I'm just stand.
Why that isn't just told to students.
It's not that hard to understand it.
Everyone wants to hear it.
It's like,
really?
I could do that.
I can do that.
It's like,
yeah,
really you could do that and the whole
society around you is labored for really
thousands of years to provide every
single one of you with this spectacular
opportunity that you have while your
undergraduates and graduate students
here.
They're just,
everyone's just praying that you would
come here and manifest everything that
you could manifest and that's what you
should be doing.
Instead of waving plot cards and
complaining about how you're oppressed
for God's sake,
you see these Yale students complaining
about their oppression.
It's just,
it just leaves me aghast and it's like,
well,
we're against the ruling class.
It's like,
no,
no.
Your baby ruling class members,
you're young.
[inaudible] the
only reason you're not rich is cause
you're young.
You know?
That's the best.
Really.
That's the,
if you look at the 1%,
even the dreaded 1% you know,
most of those people are old.
Why?
Well,
when you progress through life,
if you're reasonably successful,
you trade in your promising youth for
your wealthy old age,
but you're still blooding old when you
trade it.
When you trade your youth for that,
like if you factor age out of the
economic equation,
things look a lot different.
One.
Of course,
older people have more money.
If they have any sense,
they'd been collecting it for their
whole life.
Is that somehow unfair?
It's not unfair unless you want to want
to be poverty stricken when you're 70
and you,
and you don't want to be poverty
stricken,
pop poverty stricken when you're 70 so I
just don't understand what's happened to
the universities.
I can't believe that you're not told
when you come the first day,
look man,
you are on,
you're here on a heroic mission.
You're going to take your capacity to
articulate yourself to levels that are
undreamed of,
you're going to come out of here.
I'm unstoppable.
You're going to be able to do anything
you want.
It's like that's what you're here for.
Instead,
you're taught that.
Well,
you know,
the world's a pretty oppressive place
and you're probably the bottom of the
victim pile.
And,
and,
and there's,
there's virtually nothing you can do
about it except,
you know,
deconstruct the patriarchy and it's so
rude deed and so pathetic that that
university should be embarrassed that
that's what they're peddling to
students.
I'm embarrassed by it.
You know,
I've gone on public record telling
parents,
bloody well,
send your boys to trade school because
at least they'll learn something useful.
And that's a terrible thing for someone
like me to say it because I do believe
that the are being articulated,
an educated in the highest possible
manner is there's nothing that's better
for you and for society and why are the
why of the university's forgotten this?
Well,
that's postmodern neo Marxism for you.
You know that then the philosophy of
intense resentment and oppression and
group identity and god,
it's just pathetic.
That reason I think a lot of students
here would agree with you that one of
the main purposes of,
uh,
education and college,
particularly at Harvard,
is to develop their sense of
articulation,
their ability to read,
their ability to create a critically
think.
Then what comes after,
particularly at Harvard,
there's a big discussion on what is a
good life,
what does it mean to use those skills
that we get here and then we graduate.
What do we do from there?
Stop.
Unnecessary suffering.
That's what you do.
You know that that's your calling.
It's like you say,
well,
what do you do after you graduate?
Well,
if you graduate,
articulated and powerful,
there will be people giving you so many
opportunities.
You won't even be able to keep up with
them.
You know,
and I've worked with comp,
very,
very competent people in many different
domains in my life.
Hyper competent people.
And I can tell you some very interesting
things about hyper competent people.
The first thing is they are not selfish
and they're not greedy.
And one of the great pleasures in their
lives is to find people who have the
capacity to also be hyper competent and
to open doors for them as rapidly as
they can possibly be opened.
They delight in that because there is,
there's nothing there.
There's just very few things that are
more intrinsically meaningful.
If you're an accomplished person,
then to find young people who have the
possibility of being accomplished and
say,
hey look,
here's an opportunity for you.
It's like go out there man,
kill it.
And then they go up there and kill it
and you think right on man,
here's another opportunity to go ahead
and go there.
Nail that to anything.
No,
no.
They're all holding their wealth and
they're not going to share it with
anyone.
It's like that's absolute complete
rubbish.
And so you don't even have to worry
about what you're going to do after you
graduate from here.
If you,
if you turn yourself into half of what
you could be,
because people will be dying to offer
you every opportunity that you can
possibly make use of.
So it's,
it's,
it's a moot point.
The,
the,
the world is always desperately short of
people who can think and speak and you
think,
well,
I won't be made use of,
first of all,
you can't say that if you're an F,
if you're at Harvard for God's sake,
I mean,
people already figured out who you are.
They've already figured it out and
they're offering you the world on a,
on a gold platter.
It take it,
it's yours.
Take it.
It's like,
great man.
Put yourself together and deserve it.
That would be great.
And that's what everyone wants.
It's what your parents want.
It's also what you want.
You know it,
it's what you want.
It's what men,
it's what women want from men.
It's what men want from women.
It's like for you to be who you could be
and then the highest faculty of the
human being is articulated speech.
It's,
it's the divine faculty and there is
nothing more powerful than that.
There's nothing that's even in the same
league,
and so if you,
if you don't have faith in that,
then your,
then your priorities are misplaced and I
can't even understand why you wouldn't
have faith in that being,
say Harvard students because look where
it's got you already.
You know you're already sitting on top
of the world,
so make deserve it.
Make use of it,
right?
Go out there and fix things up.
That's what you need to do.
There's lots of things that need to be
fixed up and what you want to do is
burden yourself with so much
responsibility that you can barely stand
and then you'll get stronger trying to
lift it up and you'll be,
won't be asking,
what should I be doing with my life?
Or what's the meaning of life or any of
that.
It will be self evident.
It's self evident.
At minimum.
You can say there's more suffering in
the world and there should be,
and I could probably do something about
that and you can do something about
that.
So go do something about it.
And then there'll be less suffering in
the world.
And then when you're 80 you can look
back on your life and say,
well,
you know,
there's less suffering in the world than
there and there would have been had.
I know it existed and,
and you don't have to even have a sense
of,
of ultimate destiny or even any sort of
theistic belief to regard that as a
positive good.
Like I think it goes beyond the mere
pragmatic utility of addressing the
world's ills because I think we do live
in a,
in a world that has a transcendent
reality as well as the reality that we
can detect.
But even independently if that,
it doesn't matter.
It's like,
I mean,
this is part of the reason I like people
like Bill Gates is a great example,
man.
That guy is,
he's after five major diseases at the
same time,
right?
He's trying to wipe out polio.
He's trying to wipe out
malaria.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's trying to wipe out malaria.
It's like,
well what should you do with your life?
Well,
you know,
take a look at Bill Gates and see if you
could do something like that.
That would be good.
So I said after a penis,
and you talk about this idea of ending
unnecessary suffering and this idea of
committing one's life to that at a
minimum,
I mean that's the minimum thing that you
could do.
A lot of students I think,
accept that premise and view what
they're doing as trying to eliminate or
reduce unnecessary suffering.
And they see activism or other forms of
direct service as fulfilling that goal.
Do you simply disagree with like the
content of what they think,
the tactic that they are using to end
unnecessary suffering?
Or do you think that their motives or
their intentions are not even the same
as yours?
It's too public.
You know,
there's this,
there's this old saying from the,
from the new testament about not praying
in public.
Right.
And the idea is that if you're going to
commune for the higher good,
you should do it in private because
otherwise you're warping your ethic in
some sense by demonstrating how virtuous
you virtuous you are to the world.
It's like,
you know,
you go out there with a stick and the
sign on,
if it says I'm against poverty,
it's like,
yeah,
no kidding man.
Really?
Like it was for poverty.
No one's core poverty.
So it's,
it's,
it's an abdication of responsibility
with the mask of social virtue and you
want to solve difficult problems to see,
figure out how to get along with your
brother,
the one you've been fighting with for
five years there.
See if you can staple your family back
together,
see if he can stop fighting with your
girlfriend and have a relationship that
for more than two weeks,
you know,
it's like there are things that you
should be doing in the confines of your
own life that are private and humble,
that would,
that would constitute genuine
accomplishments.
And those are the things that you should
attend to.
And no one's going to come along and
say,
hey,
you know,
good job.
You're,
you're changing the world because it's,
it's private,
but it's real.
And then people don't do that.
And so,
no,
I don't,
I don't trust the activists.
I don't trust the activist ethos at all.
Hmm.
I think,
I think everything about it is,
is superficial and,
and trendy and,
and too easy and,
and it externalizes the blame.
The evil is always the elsewhere,
which is a dreadful mistake to make
because the evil isn't elsewhere.
That's,
that's the thing that you understand
when you're wise is the evil is not
elsewhere.
It's you because you're not everything
you could be.
And so,
you know,
you should work on that before going in
talent.
Someone else that maybe they're not who
they should be.
So I think it's,
you know,
I,
so I don't buy it.
It's too easy.
It's far too easy and it's too public
and it's too self congratulatory.
And then there's the murderous like
Marxist element,
which,
you know,
I'm always often inclined to mention.
So certainly I think you've identified
certain causes where the public element
or the self congratulatory version I'm
to do good could be harmful.
But do you think there are cases,
for instance,
I'm thinking of policy influencing
policy and being a policy maker.
It seems like something like that public
policy could be used to eliminate some
unnecessary suffering,
but would involve a more public domain.
Something where you are trying to
attract followers,
trying to attract praise from other
people.
Look,
look,
if you,
if you've established yourself in the
world as a credible human being and
people are asking you to enter public
service because of your accomplishments,
then it's time to do it,
right?
But before that,
it's a little on the premature site.
And if you're just setting your for self
forward as an Avatar of an idiot of an
ideology,
then there's nothing to you.
Except I think of it as the chattering
of various forms of demons.
It's like you're not helpful.
And if you,
if you look,
you want to think,
okay,
are you fit to lead?
That's,
let's put it that way.
Okay.
First of all,
do you know where you're going?
Because that's actually one of the
hallmarks of a leader.
Leader knows where he's going and maybe
other people are also interested in
going that way.
But the leaders I've met have carved
themselves out a personal vision,
right?
He's not some,
it's not some cookie cutter ideological
solution to the ills of the planet.
They've done a detailed analysis,
right?
They know what they're talking about and
they're usually people,
well,
they've had a successful relationship,
they've had a successful family,
they have a couple of degrees,
they've established a business like
they've made themselves credible in five
or six dimensions.
Well then maybe you know enough about
the world to dare to mess with its
internal mechanisms.
And if you,
if you don't have that kind of in depth
knowledge,
then you should just,
you shouldn't,
you should know more work on the
economic systems of Western
civilization.
Then you should try to adjust the
electronic systems of your automobile
because the latter is far less complex
than the former.
So of course there's utility in policy
formulation and in,
in government service and in all of
those sorts of things,
but you have to,
you have to have transformed yourself at
least to some degree,
into someone who's actually competent
before you should even dare to do such
things.
You think,
well,
I have read some marks and now I know
how to change the world.
Yup.
That's a very bad idea because the
probability that you're going to take
something complex that doesn't work too
badly and fix it with your idiotic
intervention is zero.
Hmm.
Well put,
we've talked a little bit about this
idea of signaling virtue and one thing
that I thought about a lot of activists
causes ones you might characterize as
self congratulatory seem to emphasize
concepts like validation and
affirmation.
In your experience,
either as a professor,
as a psychologist,
do you think that this is an example of
virtue signaling and perhaps provide
like a definition of virtual virtue
signaling first or do you think there is
some value in these types of principles
or these types of interactions?
I don't think there's any value in those
principles at all.
I mean,
I can say,
well,
I think you're a really good guy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Nope.
At most,
that's a,
well,
first of all,
it's cheap and easy,
and now I'm in the,
I'm a good guy because he's the one
perfectly willing to affirm you.
It's like
everyone has a problem.
Let's say with self affirmation.
This is why I hate that word,
but I'll use it temporarily.
Um,
this is part of the reason why I'm an
admirer of part in part of the
existential philosophers and
psychologists,
because one of the points they made is
that,
well,
human beings are flawed creatures.
W W we have tragic lives.
We're very,
very vulnerable.
And so it's very easy for us to despise
ourselves and to end,
to end,
to be empty,
to despise,
and have contempt for humanity itself.
And there are reasons for that.
We're,
we're weak,
we're flawed,
we're malevolent.
We don't last very long.
We're not very attractive.
We have,
we have an endless litany of faults,
both as a species and as individuals.
Well,
so,
so you're stuck with that.
That's just part of being itself.
It's built into the fabric of being.
So what do you do about that?
Well,
you don't go around waiting for someone
to tell you what a good person you are.
That's not,
first of all,
it's not believable.
It's not helpful.
That doesn't mean you should be
commenting people into a sense of even
more fallibility than they already have.
That's not clearly,
that's not helpful.
But the way that you develop an,
an,
uh,
a sense of respect for yourself,
which is a better way of thinking about
it or respect for humanity for that
matter,
which is much better than thinking about
it as an affirmation,
is to bear up under the damn load.
And then you can recognize yourself as
something that's flawed,
but the can tolerate the floor and that
can work towards alleviating it.
And that's,
that's the pathway to the transcendence
of tragedy,
which is a much like comparing just
affirmation.
It's like,
it's,
you're giving a starving,
you're giving a thirsty person dust to
drink.
Hmm.
There's nothing to it.
You know,
people,
it's the people have to commit to being
in order to withstand their own
vulnerability and fragility.
And,
and essentially flawed nature.
The way that you tolerate them is to,
the way you stand up underneath that is
to adapt responsibility for it and then
your pathways clear.
Then you can tolerate who you are and
then you won't hate humanity because
people hate humanity.
You hear the environmentalists,
the radical environmental is say such
things.
I've heard people say this,
the planet would be better off without
people on it.
It's like,
well,
let's keep you away from the hydrogen
bombs.
Shall we know when people think that's a
virtuous statement,
the planet would be better off without
people on.
It's like,
that's,
that's what you're saying.
It's like,
I see.
You don't think it's okay to be racially
genocidal,
but it's perfectly fine to just wipe out
all of them.
That's okay.
As long as you're not selective about
it.
So we,
we,
we're,
we're nourishing.
People were nourishing young people on
nothing.
Hmm.
It's nothing.
It's like they're suffering and no
wonder because life is suffering.
Right.
That's the first thing you learn if
you're on the road to wisdom,
life is suffering.
Right.
And is it someone's fault?
Yeah,
sure.
It's Society's fault.
It's your fault.
It's nature's fault.
It's God's fault.
It's like,
yeah,
the faults everywhere,
man.
So what are you gonna do about that?
Bear up under it and do something useful
and then you can respect yourself at
least to some degree.
At least you're not contributing to the
problem.
Yeah.
You know?
And then maybe you can start to see the
beauty in life and the possibility in
life and the majesty in life and the,
and the,
and the incredible capacity of human
beings for self transformation here.
Here's an example.
We've,
we've learned this relatively recently
and at a neuro biological level,
you know,
so there's been an idea,
psychological idea that's floated around
for quite a long time,
a clinical idea that you expand your
character by aggregating diverse
experiences,
right?
It's sort of the journey everywhere to
become who you are.
And you can think about that from,
from a Piagetian perspective,
a constructivist perspective and say,
well,
the more places you journey to in the
world,
the more information you expose yourself
to.
And then you take in that information
and inform yourself with it and you
develop yourself.
Because you're more differentiated than
you have a more differentiated view of
the world.
It's like the basic idea is the world is
a pool of information that you can use
to construct yourself out event to
construct the world.
And that's a lovely doctrine and I,
I believe that to be the case,
but there's more to it than that.
You know,
we know now that if you take someone and
you put them in in radically new
situation,
that new genes turn on in their,
in their brain at the micro,
at the,
at the microlevel new,
new new genetic structure's code for new
proteins and build new structures.
It's like you're actually a pool of
biological possibility and the only way
that you can determine the full extent
of that,
of that pool,
of the possibility of that pool is by
pushing yourself out against the world.
And that will physiologically transform
you.
And we have no idea what the limits to
that are.
We know in clinical psychology that you
know,
what you do with people is expose them
to the things that they're afraid of
vendor or avoiding.
You don't make them less afraid by doing
that,
you make them braver.
That's why it generalizes,
right?
They don't come out saying,
oh,
the world's safe.
It's like once you've learned that the
world is safe,
not safe,
there is no going back.
That's the post traumatic stress
disorder conundrum.
There is no going back.
But what you can learn is yes,
the world is terribly dangerous,
far more dangerous than you think.
And people are far more malevolent than
you likely have the imagination to,
to conceptualize.
But there is really more to you than you
know.
And if you wouldn't look for safe spaces
and retreat,
if you would push out in the world and
accept your responsibility and,
and confront your limitations,
then you would discover all sorts of
things about you that you have no idea
about.
And then you would transform it to
something that's far more than what you
are.
And,
and,
and it's in that process of continual
transformation that you'll actually find
the essential meaning of life.
So,
and again,
this is,
it's not like,
it's not like we don't know this.
Everyone knows this.
So,
and the universities in some sense
supposed to remind you of this,
but they've abdicated their
responsibility as far as I'm concerned.
And in many cases are working counter
productively.
They're trying to teach young people
that they're,
that they're helpless victims who need
to restructure society in order.
I don't know,
I can't even say it anymore.
It's so,
it's so empty and dad,
it's,
it's Ah,
you know,
I think I read this and,
and uh,
Eli is Canadian,
a book called crowds and power.
And it was one of the things that really
stuck in my imagination.
He did an atom,
a logical analysis of the word slogan,
and he said that it was derived from the
wealth,
uh,
two words slew ag es,
El you a,
g h and Gerome,
g h a,
I,
r.
M.
And it meant battle cry of the dead.
And that really struck me because I,
I've always had this sense that people
mouthing ideologies are the puppets of
corpses.
It's something like that.
Puppets of corpses of level and
philosophers now,
and they speak in dead tones and they're
not interesting.
Like if you're listening to an Indian
log of rattle,
you can hardly
concentrate on what they're saying
because it's bad.
It's death itself speaking again and it
compels zero interest.
And so even discussing this sort of
thing,
I find difficult to even formulate the
words because I'm so tired of that kind
of that realm of that realm of
discourse.
It's like with,
there's so many tremendous things that
are remaining in the world for people to
do with,
they stopped being dead puppets of,
of,
of sick ideas.
It's appalling to me that it even has,
and the opposition to that even has to
be justified.
Our entire civilization is opposition to
that.
And so,
I mean,
we can let it go if we want,
but the alternatives are far gloomier
than what we have now.
I can tell you that.
So we can let it all go and we're being
taught to let it all go.
It's corrupt.
It's rotten,
right to the roots.
It needs to be retooled late to the very
concepts that we use.
It's like,
yeah,
what's going to replace it?
What have we got this better?
You've got nothing that's better.
What we have is something that could be
far more than it is if people would just
take it to the level that it could be
taken to and everyone wants to hear that
and then we're all nuts.
It's been a very long answer.
This is why 91% of the people that are
watching my lectures are man as far as I
can tell.
Hmm.
So
that could be something we have time for
one or two more questions then we might
open it up to q and.
A one more question according to connor.
Um,
I don't want to end with it cause you
were talking about your experience as a
clinical psychologist and I'm wondering
if you have any advice for students on
general topics of like mental health,
wellness at college.
In a lot of ways,
I think you have claimed that by finding
more purpose,
by finding more meaning by contributing,
one can develop more tolerance for
oneself.
One can develop more self affirmation.
I'm wondering though,
if you think there are cases where there
are people with a lot of potential,
especially at Harvard who may doubt
their abilities,
who may get quite anxious.
I'm sure you've interacted with students
with um,
clients as a clinician.
How do you,
what advice do you give them or what do
you think college students should know
about enhancing their psychological
wellbeing at college?
We've done,
we've done some research on that topic.
I mean,
one of the things that really seems to
help is to write out your plans for the
future.
We have a program,
an online program called future
authoring that we've used with Oh 10,000
university students now and raise their
grade point average 25% drop their
dropout rate by about the same.
Uh,
it particularly works well for men who
are generally underperforming women now.
And so that,
I think it's raising them up and it also
works spectacularly well for non Western
ethnic minority men,
which was also extraordinarily positive
because you know,
that's,
that's well that that was a great
unexpected outcome.
But in some of it is to aim at something
that's worth aiming out.
Yeah.
And,
and how do you determine what's worth
aiming out?
You think,
well,
okay,
here I have my miserable wretched life.
Under what conditions would it justify
itself as far as I'm concerned
personally?
Like under what conditions would my life
justify itself?
And so you,
you think,
well,
what sort of future would I have to have
so that I can say this is worth it.
And then that's what you aim for.
And that,
and technically that works in part
because we know that most of the systems
that mediate positive emotion and human
beings,
and so those would be the dopaminergic
systems that have their roots in the
hypothalamic exploratory centers are
activated in relationship to the pursuit
of a goal,
not as a consequence of attaining
something that's a conservatory reward
system.
But human beings mostly run on incentive
reward.
And so it appears that the higher the
goal,
the more kick you get from,
from noting your progress towards that
goal.
Now you have to be careful because you
don't want to pick a goal that's so
impossible that all you ever do is fail
in relationship to it.
That's an issue of self management,
right?
You want to,
you want to pick a goal that moves you
to the next plateau that you have a
reasonable prob a reasonable but not
certain probability of attaining.
So that's,
that's part of it is to,
is to formulate a plan to decide who,
who it is,
what it is that you want to be,
who it is that you want to be from a
character logical perspective.
And if you're having other problems.
Well,
you know,
some of that is when you're talking more
on the clinical end of things is that,
again,
the devil's in the details,
but it's useful to talk to people.
It's useful to write about what it is
that you're up to it.
But it's,
it's most worthwhile to organize your
life,
I would say.
And to,
and to pick a goal into a mad it that's,
that's a very nice way of starting to
straighten things out for yourself.
So,
but I mean,
I would also say like I've had many
clients,
I often advocate the use of
antidepressants.
I mean people for example,
people have all sorts of physiological
problems that compromise their movement
forward.
And those have to be addressed.
I'm not saying that you can lift
yourself up by your bootstraps in every
possible situation.
I know that not be true.
You take whatever interventions you need
in order to allow yourself to continue
moving forward in the world.
But you know,
and what do you do to try to set
yourself up?
Well,
I have some friends that's helpful.
Have an intimate relationship.
Try to make one that's reasonably
permanent.
That's helpful.
Aim at having a family and children aim
at being useful to the community and
turning yourself into something that's
noble and respectable and powerful and,
and that'll,
that'll help you orient yourself when
you're young.
And because you'll start to see that you
could have a life that was worth living,
that you could be not proud of.
That's the wrong way of thinking about
it,
but that you could live in the right way
of phrasing it is that you could live in
a manner that justifies the fragility of
being.
That's the right way to think about it.
That's the right way to think about
because the fragility of being is a very
powerful argument against its existence
and that's been recognized by that was
that that was,
that's the fundamental ethical dilemma
investigated by Gurth F for example,
in his,
in his play foxed because Mephistopheles
is the mouthpiece of everyone who says
being is so fragile that it should be
eradicated because it produces too much
suffering.
It's Ivan chromosomes argumenting in
the,
in the brothers Karamazov it's a very
powerful argument.
Why should any of this be an announcer
is you justify it by how it is that by
how you exist,
you justify being by how you choose to
exist and you can choose to exist in a
manner that produces absolutely no
justification whatsoever for being quite
the contrary.
But that's,
that's not a pathway that I would
recommend.
Yeah.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
[inaudible]
okay.
All right.
So we have some questions I think from
the audience.
Um,
and I'm just going to read them in order
and you're going to answer com.
Pretty simple.
So our first question we have here
reads,
I'm a postdoc in the psychology
department and I'm very interested in
conducting research,
examining the extent to which highly
politically correct individuals are
analytical in parentheses or not.
I am however very concerned that this
pursuit will potentially flip to the
back proved to be quite damaging to my
reputation and that it will likely
hinder my chances of obtaining a faculty
position.
Do you have any advice for them?
Yeah,
I talked to talk to the members all the
time and they,
and they see the same thing.
I'll say what I think when I get my
first job and then they get their first
job and they say,
well,
I'll say what I think when I,
when I,
when I'm,
when I have tenure.
And then they get tenure and it's like
15 years later,
10 years later.
And they don't have anything left to say
because they haven't said anything for
the last 10 years.
And it's like,
that's no way to live,
man.
That's no way to live.
It's do your damn research.
Pick the hardest topic you can possibly
imagine and pursue it and state what you
believe to be the truth.
And let me see,
there's a rule.
There's a rule.
This is an existential rule.
And in Sweden,
one we're really worth thinking about
because it,
it's,
it's a pointer to a fundamental mode of
being.
So one mode of being involved using your
speech strategically.
And that's exactly what it is.
Questions about this,
this person is basically asking,
should I use my ability to communicate
strategically and strategically?
Is,
should I aim at getting the job I want
with my actions?
Well,
the answer to that is it's better than
not aiming at anything.
So that's one answer.
And,
and,
and it's a reasonable answer.
But here's,
here's a different answer.
This is a fundamental dilemma of faith.
I would say
the fundamental dilemma of faith is
whether or not you should live by the
truth.
Hmm.
And
you determined to live by the truth.
When you make the decision that if you
tell the truth,
the outcome is the best possible
outcome.
You see,
that's an existential decision,
right?
And it's predicated on,
it's predicated on something like faith
in the fundamental nature of being.
Because if you allow yourself to the
degree that you can with the truth,
then what you're doing is acting out the
proposition that being is structured in
the best possible manner because
otherwise you wouldn't ally yourself
with the truth and if you decided to
ally yourself with the truth and you act
in a manner of commensurate with that,
then your life will unfold in a
particular way and you have to take your
chances if you're going to live like
that.
But the advantage to that is that,
well,
one advantage is you don't compromise
yourself and maybe you don't want to
compromise yourself because yourself is
what you have to stave off the
catastrophe of being.
And if you compromise that,
then you have nothing except perhaps
what other people will give you.
It's a pathway to weakness.
Now I have a graduate student.
As it happens,
who is doing exactly that?
We started doing empirical analysis of
politically correct beliefs and it's
been absolutely fascinating.
First of all,
they do cohere.
So the way we did it was we,
we,
we collected about 400 statements that
were deemed by people in the press and
so forth as indicative of politically
correct belief.
We did that agnostically and this is a
standard standard construct validation
process in psychology is that if you
want to find out if something exists,
he wanted to find out if the elements of
that that entity say a domain of beliefs
covariates such that if you hold one
belief,
you're much more likely to hold another
belief.
And so then you can pile up the beliefs
that are likely to occur if one occurs.
And the the,
the essential way to do that is to
oversample the domain of beliefs,
subject them to a factor analysis and
see how they cohere.
And we found that there were two factors
that were associated with the
politically correct belief and that they
were very powerfully predicted by
personality and most particularly by
trait agreeableness,
which was not a predictor of
conservatism or liberalism particularly,
but,
but more to the point,
the student who's doing that,
uh,
her name is,
her name is Christine brophy.
She's very brave girl,
very,
very tough girl.
And uh,
she's,
she's pursued this forthrightly and it's
led to nothing but opportunity,
crazy amounts of opportunity.
Now it's a tough road to hoe.
She knows perfectly well.
She's not going to be very popular in
certain domains,
but,
but that's no reason not to pursue
something.
The issue is,
are you interested in it?
Do you want to find out the truth?
Are you willing to pursue it?
And Are you willing to stake yourself on
that?
And if,
if the answer is no,
then you're not willing to stake
yourself on yourself.
And then God help you because you'll
have to be given something by someone
else to stake yourself on.
And they can always take it away.
So it's like don't be thinking,
don't be thinking politically about your
career.
It's foolish.
It doesn't work.
It really doesn't work.
You'll be second rate
at fast,
you'll be second rate and frightened at
fast.
You'll never hit the top ranks if you
perform like that.
And having said that,
I would also say don't be an idiot.
Don't make unnecessary enemies.
Right?
I mean there's no point in making
unnecessary enemies.
That's,
that's not wise.
But don't sell yourself short.
You know,
you might be on the cutting edge of an
entire new domain of psychology if you
actually get it right.
And so maybe you won't be popular among
your superiors for the time being.
You can't talk to the people who are
above you in the dominance hierarchy
anyways.
It's awesome.
You can barely talk laterally.
You pretty much have to broadcast your
message down.
And so the fact that,
well enough said about that.
No,
it's a bad idea.
Pursue your damn research and tell the
truth about it and let the chips fall
where they will.
Well,
you're much better protected that way
then by doing anything else.
Second question,
how have university has been ruined by
Marxism or rather by the massive growth
of student life bureaucracies that seek
to train rather than educate.
They haven't been completely ruined,
but the humanities and the social
sciences are both in trouble.
Oh,
hi.
Could you please speak to the legitimacy
of Harvard's decision to penalize
students for being part of single gender
organizations that are not officially
recognized by the university?
Uh,
for example,
fraternities,
sororities,
and final clubs.
It's cowardly.
Hm.
It's politically correct.
It's,
it interferes with freedom of
association.
So I would think they would have more
important things to do.
All right.
Do you think,
do you think that victim hood narratives
and critiques of oppression,
which make up much of the political
discussion on college campuses are a
symptom of a psychological need to
deflect guilt because of,
because of a lack of another better
method of redemption?
Yeah,
I think that is part of it.
I mean,
because I don't,
I don't,
it's not,
I'm speaking more strongly in some sense
then perhaps would be optimal.
Partly because time is short.
I know that young people have a mess.
I,
Yanik urge Piaget actually identified
that as,
as part of the developmental process,
uh,
that that was the typified late
adolescence
and it's admirable in many ways.
It needs to be directed in the most
powerful possible,
powerful,
prosocial manner possible.
And that's what the university should be
doing.
And by training students to be noisy,
ill informed,
historically ignorant agitators,
narcissistic agitators,
let's add that they're doing them a
tremendous disservice.
Like when I was at mcmaster for example,
where the last very vocal protest
occurred mostly what I felt about the
protesters with sorrow.
Cause I,
you know,
I looked out there,
I saw,
well there's these,
there young people,
they're university students,
they're because they went to university
at least in principle to learn something
about themselves and about the world.
And instead they've been transformed
into these.
Like they were chanting,
they were chanting like
wow
profanities at me.
And really that's a best you can do
your,
if come out and you're dopey little
group,
you'll hide behind the hammer and sickle
because of one of your fashionable
professors convinced you that was a good
idea.
And the best you can do is organize
yourself and chant profanities at me.
You know,
it's so sad.
These are,
these are,
we can be doing something better than
that.
I mean card come out and they have a
useful protest of some sort.
At least if you're going to come out and
protest,
make it a high quality protest stead of
like cursing at me in repetitively.
So dowel and unimaginative and and
pathetic.
And so,
no,
I forgot what the question was.
Eight more.
Okay.
Five minutes.
In cases where people have sworn
chastity throughout life,
under voluntary and noncoercive
circumstances,
is it possible to still develop fully
and not suffer from the consequences of
having never undergone sexual
maturation?
If so,
how is it possible?
Wow,
I didn't expect that one.
I can tell Ya.
Sometimes people have to make a
sacrifice,
right?
And
everyone always has to make sacrifices.
That's actually something that I learned
from reading mythology because the
ancient myths always talk about
sacrificing people claim not to
understand what that means.
You always have to let go of something
in order to progress into the future.
In fact,
that's the most fundamental discovery
human beings ever made as far as I can
tell,
because it's,
it's exactly the same thing as
discovering the future.
And we discovered the future,
right?
We're the only creatures that we know of
who really can conceive of the future
and the future is something that's made
better by letting go of things in the
present.
Right?
That's impulse control.
And you can look at it that way if you
want.
The person who wrote this is obviously
wrestling with something,
you know,
and maybe they're wrestling with a hyper
dominant sexual impulse that,
that,
that threatens to be master instead of
servant.
And so who knows what they have to do in
order to bring themselves under control.
I would say that less radical solutions
might first be advised,
but I can write because you don't have
to,
you don't want to whip yourself with a
bigger whip then you need to use.
Right.
And I think that's,
that's minimal necessary force doctrine
essentially.
But so yeah,
so that's how I would answer that
question.
Pretty good if I want.
You weren't expecting
Dr. Peterson,
you say that the meaning of life is to
take an individual responsibility for
the burdens of existence.
If each person can justifiably choose
his own way of taking on these burdens,
then how can we prevent individuals from
committing actions that are clearly
moral injustices?
Well,
we can't.
Hmm.
I mean,
that happens all the time.
I think the best way,
there's all sorts of mechanisms for
regulating it,
right?
We have all sorts of mechanisms for
regulating it.
Civil society and policing regulates it.
Expectations between family members and
friends regulated your conscience
regulates it.
MMM.
But I don't believe that people do.
As a general rule commit illegalities or
or worse because they've taken on
responsibility.
That isn't how it works.
The pathway to criminality is not to be
found in the adoption of responsibility.
You don't say that about criminals
swallow.
If he would've just taken on a little
less responsibility than he wouldn't be
in jail.
No,
that is now.
It works.
So what the question is more something
like,
well,
if people are allowed to direct
themselves,
how do you stop them from picking a path
that's improper?
And I would say that that,
and I do believe that that's the
essential question.
And I would say part of that is that if
you're going to be self directed,
let's say at least to some degree,
then you have to tell the truth because
otherwise you pathologize yourself and
you can't rely on your own judgment
then.
And that that's part of the reason why
the truth is so necessary is that if
you're going to use yourself as the
mechanism by which you Orient Yourself
in the world and you better make sure
that you're not transforming yourself
into something that's predicated on
error.
And so,
so the,
the,
uh,
the attempt to speak the truth is as a
form of psychophysiological hygiene.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And if,
if you're oriented as well as you can
towards the articulated truth,
then you can increasingly rely on your
own judgment.
And that's,
and that's the,
that's the best defense say against,
against the dark side.
You've attached a number of useful
ideas.
If this is a fun one,
number of useful ideas,
for instance,
self overcoming personal responsibility
to a viral meme,
social justice conflict,
how can we attach and useful ideas to
the social justice side of this
controversy and convert it into a
growthful movement for all involved?
Well,
I do think that is what's happening to
some degree.
I think that the political dialogue
that's emerging is precisely that.
I don't know how we can do it.
I know what I know how I've been doing
it to some degree.
I've been doing it by saying what I
think
[inaudible]
and carefully,
you know,
and and knowing that I'm prone to error
and listening to feedback because I
would like to know where I'm making
errors.
I had advisors,
my friends,
while I was undertaking this who were
telling me constantly everything I was
doing that was second rate and and
egotistical and careless and all of
those things.
And so I would say,
okay.
I would say to some degree,
maybe that question is specified at the
wrong level of analysis is that you
should,
you should learn to articulate what you
think and that's what you have at your
disposal.
And,
and with you people in the audience,
man,
you've got power at your disposal,
you're all super bright and super
conscientious and like,
you know,
your powerhouses,
you might not know it and maybe some of
you forgotten that because you'd come to
Harvard and of course,
so 50% of you are below average at
Harvard,
but that doesn't mean that you're not
like hyper capable cause you're hyper
capable.
So get your act together and say what
you think.
And that'll do the trick,
man.
That'll,
that'll,
that'll work just fine.
Dr. Peterson,
we're running out of time.
So I'm gonna ask you one last question.
I think it's an important one,
especially for some of the people who
don't think you should be speaking here
today,
whether some of them are in this room or
some of them were outside earlier.
The question reads,
give an extremely elevated violence and
murder rates against trans people.
Why have you chosen to threat in a
population that is already facing job
discrimination,
murder,
etc.
Oh,
I'm not threatening them.
I don't think there's any evidence.
The fact that a handful of noisy
activists consider me a threat is no
criteria of proof of any sort of
anything.
And I mean so,
so I just reject that entire,
all,
every single word in that question is
meaningless as far as I'm concerned.
So people think,
someone said just because someone said
that,
what I said is a threat to trans people
does not make it true.
And I have the testimony of a fair
number of trans people that that's
actually not only not true.
It's palpably false.
So,
sorry,
not guilty.
Hm.
Very Canadian of you to apologize there.
Yeah,
but not so much to say that I'm not
guilty,
I suppose.
Yeah.
For that.
Well,
first of all,
I want,
I don't consider threats of violence,
so we have to be very careful when we
use our words.
So,
so someone saying something and
[inaudible] relatively brief or not the
same thing.
And second,
there's no possible way I can answer
that question because I know nothing
about the threats.
I know nothing about who uttered them.
I know nothing about who reported them.
It's so,
it's your question is basically,
some people said some bad things after I
taught.
It's like,
could be,
but I have no idea what to do about
that.
And I don't take responsibility for it.
It's not specific enough to take
responsibility for.
Okay.
So we do have the officers have to go
home.
Um,
I appreciate that you have an opinion,
but at some point,
um,
at some point we do need to call it a
day.
Um,
thank you.
Akash and Professor Peterson so much.
[inaudible].